hello rejects its Greg Izzy here with
Briana is eyt here from rebel girl
gaming straight rebel gaming really is
stranger rebel get it right I will get
it right one day don't work never do so
we're gonna watch the Final Fantasy 15
that's his ex video the stand together
official live-action trailer
Rihanna what information do you have to
provide a non gamer information person
like me with so this is a standalone
story okay so it's gonna not have a
story connection to any of the other
final fantasies so you don't really need
to worry about that okay cool cool oh
thank god alright that makes my life a
lot easier and just partial nudity in it
that's nothing oh yeah probably I don't
know what that means
that's find out alright I like the game
live action trailers usually I'm really
excited I haven't seen this yet
I saw the movie Final Fantasy the
Spirits Within did you like it yeah I
heard nothing to do with the game her
wasn't much you wouldn't like it King is
dead
okay
[Music]
[Music]
like stranger things
[Music]
ah sweet
[Music]
that is so cool extra tree wow it's
final fantasy 15 at Gamestop I got
chills from that do you play this game
on your channel oh yeah I am I haven't
started it yet it came out yesterday
technically like yesterday at 12 a.m.
and I haven't started it yet because he
wasn't sure if I was gonna stream it or
record it and I think I'm gonna record
it for a little while and then maybe
stream after so that's really cool wanna
see a playthrough of it go check out my
channel I'll definitely keep a lookout
for that thanks love however even movie
trailers they keep doing these covers
I'm like all the trailers every trailer
has like I forgot it
I don't know how I felt about it for
this honestly it was in the song stand
by me feels slightly misplaced here ever
so slightly but it's interesting because
the aesthetic of this game is set with
modern type technology but in a magical
fantasy world injury so I watched Kings
glaive last night and there was you know
these men in like regal robes and
magical powers and lightning but then he
had like a cellphone and like a
Bluetooth it was very like contrasting
I'm much it's building on that the
game's modern-day this one right I don't
think it's set in a time period of our
world it's all fantasy so as I saw
snippet of Conan O'Brien playing yeah
yeah yeah I remember there was like the
carrier's like pushing a car around and
stuff right yeah that's kind of what I'm
talking about is like if there's like an
Audi in it okay you know you know what I
mean and the city insomnia looks like a
regular old city like New York or Tokyo
or whatever yeah yeah building on that
contrast I still don't know if I like it
even knowing that I still don't know if
I like the song choice
have you played most of the other games
I played a ton of Final Fantasy 14 but
totally different games is it supposed
to be like a like a soft reboot for
Final Fantasy like not really it's just
still just its own standalone though so
it's not like an immediate sequel though
anything no okay yeah and that's why
there's so much multimedia content that
comes with it like these trailers and
like
glaive which is a full movie and like
Brotherhood which is like a TV episodic
series kind of thing okay okay is a lot
of information it was a little bit
intimidating for me as well I was like I
have to watch a feature-length movie
before I can understand the game yeah
really
but with these games they're so
immersive and they're so full world you
really do want to get the the full story
alright alright I don't really get why
they were children in this trailer oh I
took it as you know like this this games
honi I thought the trailer was like kind
of honing in on the fantasy element yes
definitely
cuz that's why I said in the middle of
it like it's kinda reminds you like
stranger things yeah little kids in over
their heads dealing with like big
creatures and [ __ ] like that yeah and
maybe this is something that will make
sense in like a plotline of the game
with like the children in that ball and
like setting a trap for them yes monster
maybe but I think it also has to do with
the fact that Final Fantasy 15 is a
group combat game you do have four
different players that has live combat
which is very different from other final
fantasies of the past which are
turn-based combat I know the exact
difference yeah a turn-based like RPG no
no Jeremy no what kind of out okay we're
kind of out of it okay near the channel
you can subscribe today become a reject
Briana is a strange rebel gaming channel
you should go check out her channel
there's a lot of Let's Plays on there
and she occasionally has did she just do
some things with Alyssa or is that a
hurt yeah yeah no I did a video with
Alyssa and we did a is Pokemon go dead
yes and I said yes it definitely is
unless they bring some crazy updates
that have been long awaited it was the
whole detailed review well we're gonna
watch a Pokemon video next actually so
keep it what's trending people